propose que nous reprenions notre
séance qui se poursuit donc
par l'audition de Madame jel Munier de
Monsieur Patrick stenmetz et de Monsieur
Pascal LAL qui
sont qui ont été en charge d'un rapport
commis par l'Inspection générale de la
justice et l'inspection générale de
l'administration
ensuite des
événements de violence urbaine qui se
sont déroulé sur notre territoire du 27
juin au au 7 juillet dernier
euh je vous remercie de vous
installer je rappelle que nous avons
créé une mission au sein de la
commission des lois que cette mission a
reçu les pouvoirs d'une commission
d'enquête euh et nous débutons donc euh
les audition par par vous-même qui avez
commis ce rapport et je sans attendre je
vais vous laisser la parole je sais pas
si vous avz prévu un ordre particulier
vous êtes organisé c'est très bien et on
va vous écouter donc vous avez ici
devant vous les
membres de la commission des lois du du
Sénat et nous sommes à votre écoute on
s'est donné le temps nécessaire pour
pouvoir échanger ensuite après vos
interventions c'est-à-dire grosso modo
midi quart quoi voilà pour faire simple
c'est peut-être vous madame et bien
madameier vous avez la parole je vous
remercie monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il me revient
donc de débuter cette présentation des
travaux qui ont été conduits comme vous
l'avez dit par l'Inspection générale de
l'administration et l'inspection
générale de la justice cette
présentation se fera donc à trois voies
je débuterai en vous présentant en
introduction quelques propos sur la
méthodologie qui a conduit qui a présidé
à nos travaux puis par une
présentation de la typ cité par
notamment l'étendue géographique et la
densité de ces violences Monsieur
Patrick stemetz donc inspecteur général
de la justice poursuivra avec la
présentation de la réponse
judiciaire je vous présenterai ensuite
les profils des auteurs condamnés et
Monsieur Pascal LAL inspecteur général
de l'administration conclura en vous
présentant les motivations des des
auteurs et peut-être les suites qui
pourrai être donné à nos travaux comme
je l'indiquaé euh il nous a semblé
important de vous décrire d'abord la
méthodologie que nous avons suivie dans
ces dans ces travaux car elle vous
donnera toute la mesure de cette
photographie à un instant T que révèle
notre rapport tout d'abord la mission a
sollicité bien entendu les servicees
statistiques des deux ministères qu'il
s'agisse du ministère de l'intérieur ou
du ministère donc de la la justice euh à
partir des applicatifs que chacun dont
chacun dispose ces données statistiqu
nationale ne sont pas des données
interconnectées de sorte qu'il faut
savoir que il n'est pas possible
statistiquement de suivre une procédure
à partir de son de son début par les
forces de sécurité intérieure et puis
jusqu'à son achèvement par la
justice donc euh nous avons dû
évidemment procéder et apprécier ces
données de façon euh séparé par ailleurs
euh il n'existe pas si on doit on doit
définir la nature des infractions qui
devaient rentrer dans notre périmètre
d'examen et de ces statistiques il
n'existe pas et vous le savez
pertinemment d'infraction de violence
urbaine il s'agit d'un panel
d'infraction qui euh nous nous sommes
inspirés des faits antérieurs de
violence urbaine pour définir le panel
sur lequel nous voulions nous pencher
avec une liste quand même de près de 500
euh types types différents d'infraction
de code dit Natinf que nous avons euh
regroupé en 10 grandes catégories
d'infractions en faisant des agrégats de
d'infraction pour que notre rapport soit
euh plus lisible mais vous comprenez
bien que euh cette méthodologie impose
peut-être
moins de finesse que nous
l'aurions voulu et que elle implique
également donc de ne pas pouvoir faire
toujours la part des choses entre par
exemple un vol aggravé puisquon il est
aggravé par différentes circonstances
mais on ne sait pas
précisément avec quelle finesse nous
avons ensuite procédé et compléter ces
exploitations de données statistiques
par l'exploitation de
euh
395 dossiers de majeur définitivement
condamné au 31 juillet 2023 c'est-à-dire
que nous avons fait le choix d'examiner
inconcretto dans 32 tribunaux
judiciaires hexagonaux les dossiers de
condamnés définitifs donc sur cette
échantillon pourquoi des condamnations
définitives au 31 juillet il s'agissait
donc pour nous nous avons débuté nos nos
travaux fin fin juillet début août il
s'agissait donc d'avoir véritablement
des des faits non contestables et comme
je dis des
des des personnes définitivement jugé
cette étude a été faite donc avec
l'examen des des dossiers sur la base
d'une grille d'analyse portant le
standardisé systématisé pardon euh qui
va nous permettre ensuite d'analyser
justement les profils notamment et les
motivations que nous vous exposerons et
euh nous avons circonscrit bien sûr euh
ces ces faits aux faits commis entre le
27 juin et le 7 juillet 2023 qui était
la période visée par notre
euh feuille de notre lettre de mission
donc analyse statistique avec les les
limites que je vous ai indiqué à euh
analyse inconcretto de d'examen
véritablement et d'un échantillonnage de
sur 32 tribunaux judiciaires
hexagonaux et 83 entretiens d'acteurs
judiciaaires et associatifs pour
compléter ce qui était une analyse
vraiment statistique et des dossiers
mais par des appréciations de ceux qui
ont été directement confrontés à ces
événements nous vous présentons donc une
photo à un instant T celui de la
rédaction de notre travail puisque vous
le comprenez nécessairement nous l'avons
limité dans le temps et puis vous le
savez le travail des forces de sécurité
intérieure le travail des tribunaux
judiciaires c'est bien bien évidemment
poursuivi que ce soit pendant il était
en œuvre pendant nos travaux et il s'est
poursuivi au-delà des des
interpellations ont encore lieu et ont
eu lieu ces ces derniers jours j'ajoute
évidemment aussi que les dossiers qui
étaient en cours par exemple à
l'instruction les informations
judiciaires qui étaient ouvertes ne nous
étaient pas accessibl et donc ce sont
des dossiers qui seront envisagés dont
l'analyse pourra être faite
ultérieurement ces précisions apporté
sur notre
méthodologie j'en viens à vous présenter
tout d'abord en quoi ces violences
urbaines nous sont apparus à typique
atypique par leur étendue géographique
et leur
densité un nombre en effet considérable
d'infraction a été constaté concentré
dans le temps euh mais plus étendu
géographiquement que jamais du 27 juin
au 7 juillet donc cette période d'examen
58297 infractions ont été constatées
réparties sur soit 66 départements 516
communes dont 23 en zone gendarmerie
euh nous avons sans pouvoir faire un
comparatif complet mais nous avons quand
même constaté que cela contrastait
significativement avec l'épisode de
violence urbaine qui pouvait être le
plus rapprochable de nos événements
c'est-à-dire celui de 2005 puisquen 2005
25 départ appartement avait été touché à
un peu plus de 200 communes
concernées cet épisode de violence
urbaine de 2005 avait d'ailleurs
concerné essentiellement d'abord des
agglomérations urbaines et puis en leur
sein des quartiers dit sensible
rattachable notamment au label quartier
prioritaire de la politique de la ville
ou quartier de reconquête républicaine
celui de
2023 euh ne nous a pas paru aussi euh
significativement marqué par ses
caractéristiques socio-démographiques ou
économique étant préciser que nous
n'avons pas pu dans le délai qui nous
était impimportti faire d'analyes
spécifique lié au quartier justement
reconquête républicaine au quartier
politique de la ville puisqu'il s'agit
d'une analyse qui est faite par les
services inter services statistiques du
ministère de l'intérie érieur une fois
par an avec des géolocalisations des
lieux où ça se produit en lien avec
l'INC donc cette étude sera certainement
faite mais nous ne l'avions pas à notre
disposition comme élément de de
comparaison nous n'avons pas non plus pu
analyser exactement les causes de
l'extension géographique qu'on a aperçu
par rapport à 2005 faudra certainement
la compléter avec l'étude sur
l'évolution des déplacements des
populations en revanche les dans les
dossiers examinés par la Mission la
moitié des personnes
condamnées été condamné pour des faits
commis dans sa commune de résidence
l'autre moitié s'est déplacé pour aller
les per perpétré ailleurs à l'aide soit
d'un véhicule personnel soit de
transport en commun ou euh à pied donc
ce qui limite quand même euh la le
déplacement euh la
les atteintes les les infractions qui
ont été commises sur cette période sont
essentiellement des atteintes au bien en
tout cas elles ont été
majoritaires 75 % hein des infractions
néanmoins ces émeutes se
singularisent par un nombre significatif
d'atteintes aux personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique nous sommes à
pratiquement à l'époque où nous avons
examiné fait à 2000 et de violence à
l'encontre des élus et personnes
chargées de mission de service
public s'agissant de la cinétique de ces
violences de leur déroulement sur
l'ensemble du territoire hexagonal que
nous avons seul examiné dans le temps
qui nous était imparti cette cinétique
est relativement homogène elle s'inscrit
elle se décrit de la façon suivante dès
la soirée du 27 juin on va apercevoir
des tirs d'engin pyrotechniqu et de
projectile incendiaire notamment à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre des
forces de sécurité et avec une
surreprésentation de ces violences dans
la première couronne fr de de l'ouest
francilien avec évidemment nan comme
épicentre la première nuit voire les
deux premières nuits
euh est une sont des nuits relativement
complexes à gérer pour les forces de
sécurité intérieure dont l'objectif
prioritaire a été la sauvegarde des
biens et des personnes objectif
prioritaire et qui a pris le pas
nécessairement sur la judiciarisation
des faits nous développerons ensuite les
les conséquences sur l'examen que nous
avons fait des dossiers le pic des
infractions on nous on a pu nous dire
par exemple que certains commissariats
ont été comparés à Fort àamot tant ils
étaient pris et C encerclé on nous a
parlé de nuit d'enfer enfin les les
forces de sécurité intérieure qui sont
intervenu sur ces deux première nuit le
pic des infractions a été constaté entre
le 29 juin et le 2 juillet avec
notamment des vols aprèsraction de
magasins qui se situent là sur ces donc
après ces deux nuits hein à partir du 29
juin 29 30 juin et ensuite une forte
décru cette forte décru très
significative euh ces causes telles que
nous avons pu les mettre en évidence
sont apparues diverses il est évident
que la stratégie euh de rétablissement
de l'ordre mené par les forces de
sécurité intérieure a été
euh particulièrement
effixiante la réponse judiciaire
également apportée rapide et cohérente
et sur laquelle un certain nombre de
chefs de juridiction n'ont pas hésité à
communiquer nous a nous est apparu comme
étant une des causes tout comme les
actions qui ont pu être prises par les
autorités local tel que l'arrêt des
transports en commun en fin d'après-midi
ou en début de soirée d'autres facteurs
ont été évoqué mais avec des
des de façon plus contrastée euh le
manque de
munition après quelques jours la
lassitude la perspective de départ en
vacances pour pour certaines familles le
rôle des familles également ou le rôle
de réseau délinquants plus structurés
mais les les appréciations été plus
contrasté
euh voilà décrit rapidement à la fois
l'étendu géographique tout à fait
atypique de ces violences urbaines leur
densité et je passe la parole à mon
collègue pour vous présenter la réponse
judiciaire réponse judiciaire qui a
conduit à des condamnations
à bref
délai
merci effectivement il nous a été
demandé de de de de faire à la date du
31 juillet euh
un un bilan des condamnations qui
étaient intervenues à ce moment-là comme
ma collègue vous l'a vous l'a indiqué
euh la
situation nous étions à moins d'un mois
après après les les émeutes la situation
a pu évoluer depuis et c'était vraiment
les premières
données et les premières réponses
pénales qui avaient été données par les
juridictions une autre précision est que
la lettre de mission nous avait demandé
et avait délimiter le périmètre de de
notre mission euh envers les majeurs il
nous était demandé donc
d'analyser le la situation des majeurs
condamnés d'analyse leur profil nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure il nous a
quand même même apparu important de de
faire le le bilan des mineurs et des
majeurs qui avaient été identifiés au 31
juillet et dont les parquet avait été
saisis et il apparaît qu'à cette date-là
que un peu plus de 4000 auteurs mineurs
et majeurs confondus euh lié au violence
urbain donc mise en cause pour l'une des
500 infractions
euh que que ma collègue a a a rappelé
euh donc avait été identifié par les
forces de l'ordre et les parquets
avaient été saisis de ces procédures ce
qui concernait à peu près un peu plus de
fait tout
confondu à cette date là 84 % ce qui est
un chiffre extraordinairement élevé
avait été poursuivi devant une
juridiction de jugement et
un/ers un peu plus d'un/ers avait été
condamné à la date du du 31 juillet
alors ces chiffres sont sont néanmoins à
prendre avec précaution puisque nous ne
sommes partis que des procédures qui
avaient été transmises au parquet et
enregistré par les parquets je dirais
que les procédures avec des dates de
poursuite plus lointaines il nous avait
été indiqué notamment que dans certains
ressorts des hémetiers étaient convoqués
fin 2023 voire début au 1ier trimestre
2024 et les procédures par exemple pour
lesquelles aucun auteur n'a pu être
identifié et bien viendront
progressivement
euh seront progressivement transmis au
parquet et viendront bien
évidemment modifier les pourcentages que
que nous avons que nous
avons noté noté calculés noté dans notre
rapport il nous a été demandé donc de
nous intéresser essentiellement enfin
exclusivement au majeur et donc nous
avons analysé à partir des des données
que que les servic statistiques du
ministère de la Justice nous a communi
iquer la nature des peines qui avaient
été prononcées pour ces pour pour ceux
qui avaient été donc jugés à cette date
là je dirais que sans surprise 60 %
d'entre eux avaient été condamnés à une
peine d'emprisonnement ferme par
définition ils ont été jugés selon des
procédures dites rapides soit de
comparition immédiate soit de compartion
sur reconnaissance préalable de
culpabilité sur des ferments euh et
parmi ces peines d'emprisonnement ferme
qui ont été
prononcées un peu plus de la moitié ont
été immédiatement
incarcéré pour les autres euh 20 % ont
bénéficié d'un aménagement de peine à
l'audience et euh pour les autres ces
peines euh d'emprisonnement ferme euh
donc ils ont été condamnés devant un
juge de l'application des peines en vue
d'examiner les modalités de cette
aménagement euh la quantum moyen de ces
peines d'emprisonnement était de 9 mois
ce qui est inférieur à la moyenne je
dirais annuelle constaté qui est qui est
de de 12 mois sachant néanmoins que les
juridictions correctionnelles sont
appelées à juger aussi des faits euh
punis de de peine supérieure comme des
trafic de de de stupéfiant ou des
infractions en bande organisée et
commise aussi sur des périodes beaucoup
plus longues donc je dirais que euh
cette indication est à relativisée
concernant les peines d'emprisonnement
ferme et les incarcétion immédiates là
encore euh la proportion est plus élevée
que la moyenne mais je dirais que le
champ de comparaison le champ des
infractions euh
que que nous avons pris en compte est
très atypique puisqu'il ne tient
absolument pas compte je dirais des
autres infractions jugées selon des
modes de poursuite plus classiques ou
plus longs
euh par par les tribunaux euh nous
noterons également que euh au-delà des
peines d'empris ronnement ferme pour les
les 40 % de de d'auteurs condamnés à une
autre nature de peine 20 % d'entre eux
ont enfin pardon euh donc sur 20 %
d'auteurs euh donc euh en plus de des 60
% qui ont été condamnés à une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme ont été condamnés
à une peine qui entraîne un suivi par
l'administration pénitentiaire que ce
soit un surcis probatoire un travail
d'intérêt général une détention à
domicile sous surveillance électronique
ou euh une peine de stage sachant que
dans ces cas-là euh c'était des stages
de citoyenneté qui majoritairement ont
été
prononcés je redonne la parole à ma
collègue pour euh pour la suite et
notamment le profil euh de ces
condamnés alors le profil de de ces
condamnés donc vous avez compris limité
aux auteurs condamnés de façon
définitive au 31 juillet dans ce que
nous avons pu observer dans ce euh panel
représentatif mais également sur les
données statistiques et avec les limites
que nous vous avons indiqué sur la
méthodologie j'ajoute que pour définir
ce profil que je vais vous
présenter va vous parler
euh notamment par exemple de leur
diplôme de leur situation familiale ou
de leur situation d'emploi il s'agit
d'éléments qui figurent dans les
dossiers mais qui résultent de données
déclaratives de la part des des
inéressés qui ne repose pas sur une
vérification faite par les forces de
sécurité intérieure au moment des
interpellations au moment des gardes à
vue on ne vérifie on peut vérifier la
nationalité on ne vérifie pas si
monsieur ou madame qui déclare avoir le
bac a réellement ou pas le bac euh donc
le profil que nous vous présentons est
un profil donc avec ces ces limites et
susceptible donc d'évoluer puisqu'on
vous a dit hein qu'on a pas pu
appréhender tout ce qui est encore en
cours à la fois à l'instruction à la
fois dans les enquêtes sur notamment les
prélèvements d'ADN qui ont pu être
réalisé les exploitations de téléphone
tout ça va compléter notre démarche ce
profil euh sans pouvoir être
extrêmement détaillé ne faire qu'un seul
profil mais nous est apparu néanmoins
comme sur le plan
socio-démographique relativement
homogène et je vais me risquer à vous
donner ce ce ce profil tel qu'il est et
tel qu'il nous apparaît à savoir un
homme de nationalité française je je
préciserai les
pourcentages moyenne d'âge 23 ans
célibataire sans
enfant hébergé souvent par ses parents
euh ayant un diplôme de niveau
secondaire maximum
baccalauréat plutôt en activité et euh
voilà pour le profil
socio-démographique des petits points de
précision j'ai dit de nationalité donc
des hommes 91 % d'hommes de nationalité
française 71 % sont de nationalité
française 75 sont nés en
France les statistiques que nous avons
ne répertorie que la nation é et le lieu
de naissance donc nous ne pouvons donner
que des éléments à la fois sur la
nationalité sur le lieu de
naissance sur donc 87 % de célibatair
pas d'enfant pas d'enfant à charge 61 %
ont un emploi une activité
professionnelle suivent une formation
donc en fait 39 % se déclareent chômeur
ou sans
activités voilà pour le profil
socio-démographique nous avons ensuite
révélé un profil judiciaire que nous
avons qualifié de plus contrasté parce
que nous avons bien conscience de la
façon dont les choses peuvent être
envisagées puisque 57 % de ces auteurs
condamnés définitif au 31 au 31 juillet
57 % sont sans antécédent judiciaaires
évidemment 43 ont des antécédents
judiciaires donc voilà le la signne
pourquoi nous avons choisi ce
qualificatif de contraster
euh puisque la majorité pas si
significative que ça euh dans ceux qui
sont euh déjà euh condamnés bien sûr les
condamnation au vu de leur jeune âge
hein puisque je vous ai dit 23 ans de
moyenne date ou remonte à 1 an ou à 18
mois auparavant et dans les personnes
condamnées 10 des 10 % des condamnations
on étaient prononcées avec la mention de
la récidive légale donc ils étaient en
état de récidive légale au sens
juridique ça ne veut pas dire de la
réitération peut-être certains étaient
en réitération c'est-à-dire recommencer
des faits mais la récidive légale c'est
une notion juridique euh de de même
infraction ou d'infraction similairire
donc 10 % étit en état euh de récidive
légale voilà pour la présentation des
personnes majeures condamnées
définitivement au 31 juillet comme l'a
dit mon collègue nous n'avions pas
directement dans notre lettre de mission
l'examen du profil des mineurs néanmoins
nous devions appréhender les mineurs
lorsqu'ils étaient en coaction avec des
majeurs les mineurs bénéficient vous le
savez d'une procédure de de jugement qui
est différente de celle des majeurs et
qui s'inscrit dans une temporalité
également différente de sorte que nous
avons euh peu de mineurs définitivement
condamnés au 31 juillet donc le profil
que je vais vous présenter des mineurs
qui représentai quand même 28 % des
auteurs au total euh se base sur des
données statistiques nationales et puis
sur quelques éléments qui ont pu
être issus d'une d'une enquête aussi qui
a été réalisée par la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse qui n'est pas
notre ce n'est pas nous qui l'avons
réalisé euh mais sur des données déc
tive et on retrouve quand même les
grands traits de ce qu'on a vu pour des
majeurs à savoir 96 % de
garçons 81 % de nationalité
française 59 % sont âgés entre 16 et 17
ans peut-être la particularité c'est que
36 % des mineurs sont des Franciliens
c'estàdire beaucoup vraiment
une quand même une une part
significative qui ont agi dans la
couronne franilienne et plutôt concerné
par pour 23 % par desme plus par des des
des atteintes au
bien s'agissant des antécédents
judiciaires nous n'avions pas ces
éléments dans les statistiques analysés
puisque je vous l'ai dit il n'y avait
peu de d'auteur définitivement condamné
on peut juste retenir que à peu près 70
% sont sans antécédents judiciaires
d'après les données déclaratives qui ont
été faites au moment de leur
déferrement devant les services de la
Protection Judiciaire de la Jeunesse
voilà pour ce profil des majeurs donc
avec des éléments plus conséquents et
des mineurs avec les quelques petits
éléments que nous avions dans notre
lettre de
mission alors je poursuis si vous voulez
bien sur sur la question des motivations
des des auteurs des violences urbaines
c'était un sujet qui nous
était imparti par la lettre de mission
et sur laquelle nous avons effectivement
travaillé mais dans je dirais dans des
conditions
qui permett de discerner les principales
motivations mais en tenant compte du
fait que on a travaillé sur les
déclarations faites par les auteurs
interpellés et qu'on a retrouvé dans les
différentes procédures que nous avons
étudié c'est-à-dire des des déclarations
faites dans une stratégie de défense
avec parfois malgré l'interpellation en
flagrant d'lit la négation de la
participation au faits qui leur été
imputé nous avons travailler également à
partir des entretiens des nombreux
entretiens que nous avons conduit avec
les magistrats tant du parquet que du
siège qui eux ont eu face à eux les
personnes mises en cause et qui ont pu
en tirer aussi des éléments de
motivation et puis nous avons bénéficié
des premières analyses du renseignement
territorial à la suite de euh cet
épisode on peut euh conclure quelques
axes majeurs d'abord par rapport à à
l'événement déclencheur de ces violences
urbaines qui est le décès du jeune Naël
à nanter on a moins de 8 % euh des euh
condamnés qui font référence à cet
événement pour justifier de leur
comportement dans le cadre euh des
émeutes en second point
euh les contestations enfin que l'on qui
apparaissent à travers
euh les attaques contre les forces de
sécurité ou les destructions euh de
bâtiments publics ne sont pas revendiqué
par les auteurs des faits
euh c'est quelque chose qui paraît
plutôt dans je dirais dans la pratique
habituelle de certains d'entre eux 3è
point la majorité la totalité au quasi
totalité des condamnés n'exprime aucune
revendication d'ordre idéologique ou
politique qui soit
susceptible de motiver une forme de
poire et une expression de la
violence on constate toutefois que ces
actions et quand on voit les
déclarations des mises en cause ces
actions dénotent un rapport très
décomplexé des auteurs des faits par
rapport à l'expression de la violence
c'estàdire que ça
paraît sans limites sans
barrières en terme en terme de de valeur
et y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
d'agression physique à l'encontre des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publicque sur la question des pillages
puisque on a eu énormément de de
magasins pillers c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu nouveau dans le dans
l'histoire des violences urbaines en
France on est très clairement sur de
l'opportunisme il faut quand même
souligner que parmi les personnes
interpelé pour lesquels nous avons
étudié les dossiers on n pas forcément
les casseurs les casseurs étaient
d'après ce qu'on a pu
apprendre des des magistrats interviewés
étaient plutôt bien organisés mais on a
des gens qui suivaient ou qui ont été
rametés sur telle ou telle grande
surface en disant bah on peut y aller et
on peut servir donc c'est vraiment de
l'opportunisme et pour certains il
revendiquit un besoin d'adrénaline voir
il se disait poussé par une ambiance
festive
enfin il faut quand même noter ce que ce
qui a été dit par ailleurs notamment par
la presse ou par certains analystes la
majorité des personnes condamnées
étaient quand même très relié aux
réseaux sociaux alors soit dans des
boucles qui les ont incité à rejoindre
des lieux d'affrontement ou des lieux de
pillage so soit tout simplement sur des
réseaux sociaux sur lesquels il y avait
des posts euh non nombreux qui mettaiit
en valeur entre guillemets l'expression
de la violence dans tel ou tel dans tel
ou tel
quartier ce qui nous remonte également
et ce qui apparaît c'est que on a très
clairement parmi parmi ces jeunes
majeurs qui ont été interpellés et
condamnés un déficit d'ancrage citoyen
et certains travailleurs sociaux que
l'on a pu interview ou pour lesquels on
on on a eu des remontées intéressantes
nous disent que beaucoup d'entre eux
étaient inconnus de leur dispositif
d'accompagnement social donc on peut
supposer je dis bien on peut supposer
que depuis 2005 et peut-être à cause de
l'épisode covid on a un certain nombre
de jeunes gens qui sont passés sous les
radars de la de la prise en compte et de
l'accompagnement alors qu'en temps je
dirais plus classique ils auraient pu
être pris en compte voilà donc on est
sur des motivations qui je pense ne vous
étonneront pas qui sont diverses mais
qui sont très minoritairement liés à
l'événement déclencheur de de cet
épisode je reprends la parole peut-être
pour un petit propos conclusif avant de
répondre bien
évidemment le micro pour qu'on vous
entende merci à à toutes vos questions
car nous avons essayé d'être ramassé
dans notre présentation et donc on n'a
pas tout développé de nos de nos travaux
pour préciser qu'effectivement les
motivations qui vous ont été présentées
euh peuvent varier aussi sur les
territoire hein puisqu'on avait centré
quand même notamment autour de la
revendication autour de du décès de Naël
était beaucoup plus forte en anterre ou
dans comme je l'ai dit dans la la la
couronne de l'Ouest franilien que à
saint-briux ou à Marseille voilà ces
propos l'ensemble de nos
travaux devrai être complétés par une
étude une recherche puisque la trisème
le 3è item de notre lettre de mission
était de nous attacher nous avons nous
pensions pas le développer précisément
mais de nous attacher aux conditions
dans lesquelles les chercheurs pour les
conditions jur jdique et opérationnel
dans lesquels les chercheurs pourraient
avoir accès aux données pénales issu
enfin liées à ces violences urbaines
donc nous avons dans une troisème partie
de notre rapport développer l'ensemble
de
ces éléments qui sont à la fois
juridique technique et opérationnel on
pourra bien sûr le l'indiquer et donc
cette étude devrait pouvoir peut-être
compléter cette photographie que nous
nous vous présentons à cette instanté et
cette étude évidemment sera plus à
distance et plus à temps euh des des
fait directement
observés merci Madame euh merci messieur
alors certains ont demandé la parole je
pense en particulier à François bonhomme
qui a souhaité s'exprimer merci monsieur
le Président merci mesdames et messieurs
de de ces propos qui viennent de nous
éclairer sur les conditions de lesquel
cet émeut assez hors norme c'est s
déroulé c'est déclenché je pense qu'on
apprend beaucoup de choses sur à la fois
sur les profils le mode opératoire moi
je voulais revenir sur un élément
particulier vous avez des noté entre
guillemets l'ambiance festive et je
crois qu'il y a une une d singularité ça
a été quand même j'allais dire le
l'alliance des réseaux sociaux et des
mortiers
d'artifice et je vous vouis savoir si
dans vos analyses si vous aviez des
préconisations quoi des analyses
particulières sur l'usage totalement
détourné qui a été fait à ce momentl des
mortiers d'artifice et notamment leur
rôle dans l' déclenchement d'incendie
puisque une des formes particulières de
ces émeut ça a été la multiplicité des
incendies que soit de voitures mais plus
encore de bâtiments et vous avez même
noté que vous aviez fait le choix enfin
le choix de du ministère public de de
sauvegarder les
biens
des personnes évidemment qui a pris le
pas sur la judiciarisation donc on voit
bien qu'il y a eu un effet retard pour
les raison qu'on peut comprendre
aisément sur la judiciarisation parce
que il y avait cette cette
multiplication d'incendies qui a non
seulement occuper les forces de l'ordre
et les et les pompiers qui ont été en
plus l'objet de d'un ciblage
particulierin en tant qu'autorité
publique et et donc les mortiel incendie
sans doute son monde atire qui a été
vraiment largement développé et qui
s'est propagé puisque à quelques clics
en quelques euros on pouvait malgré la
réglementation se procurer ce type
d'arme par destination donc je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des préconisation
particulière ou en terme de
réglementation ou autre sur l'usage qui
a été fait de ces mortiers d'artifice
merci monsieurame une autre demande je
propose qu'on la prenne madame
Dumont merci Monsieur le présid
président merci madame messieurs pour la
qualité de de de votre rapport et des
éléments que vous avez bien voulu nous
nous nous partager nous faire partager
moi je je souhaiterais avoir quelques
éléments de de précision sur les stages
de citoyenneté monsieur vous avez parlé
de stage de citoyenneté auquel devaient
se soumettre les personnes pouvons alors
avez-vous un retour sur l'effectivité de
ces stages de ces stages de citoyenneté
ont-ils é effectué de quelle nature
était-il et est-il prévu un suivi
[Musique]
euh des personnes qui se qui ont
effectué ces stages de citoyenneté
est-ce que ça a porté ses fruits est-ce
que ce sont des gens qui après se
remettent dans dans dans le bon chemin
voilà merci de de ces
précisions merci pour l'instant j'ai pas
d'autre ah allons-y m si oui merci euh
j'ai une une demande de précision vous
avez parlé de de la désescalade d'une
part de quand il y a eu la
désescalade sur le le le rôle des des
familles et des parents mais vous avez
aussi parlé des des réseaux
euh de délinquant de délinquence plus
structuré je voudrais avoir des
précisions sur ce que vous entendez par
là et quel est le rôle possiblement de
effectivement de de ces réseaux
criminels qui existent et et sur où dans
l'incitation au départ euh de ces
émeutes ou pas ou à l'inverse dans euh
le fait que euh ils aent joué un rôle
pour le retour dans de l'ordre et et et
dans dans ce cas quelles sont leurs
motivations euh sur ce ces
interventionsl euh et puis euh si vous
pouvez donner plus d'éléments sur les
différences que vous avez un petit peu
mentionné sur les les zones euh très
urbaines et notamment franceyenne parce
qu'il y a des particularités sur
l'île-de-fance par rapport à d'autres
zones et notamment par rapport aux me de
2005 le fait qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
petites communes et de moyennes communes
qui ont été touchées et est-ce que vous
avez des éléments par rapport au au aux
motivations ou aux profils sociaux qui
peuvent expliquer ça merci madame
naraiga monsieur Bourgi et Madame aribet
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame messieur je voulais vous
remercier pour la qualité et les
précisions chirurgicales que vous venez
de nous présenter euh effectivement ils
viennent confirmer ce que j'avais
observé dans mon département à travers
la lecture quotidienne de la PQR qui
rendait compte des comparitions
immédiates qui avait eu lieu et on s'est
rendu compte que finalement il y a
beaucoup de délinquence par
opportunisme délinquence par
opportunisme et les chiffres que vous
avez communiqué viennent l'objectiver le
confirmer puisqueeffectivement je crois
que c'est 6 % seulement des mises en 8 %
des mises en cause qui font référence à
la mort du jeune Naël la deuxième chose
que j'avais observé c'était le ciblage
d'un certain certain types de commerce
qui revenait de manière récurrente à
savoir de la captation de produits de
marque euh destiné à des public on va
dire générationnel
euh ce que je voulais aussi avoir comme
précision vous l'avez indiqué à savoir
la mobilisation via les réseaux sociaux
et via les boucles je voulais avoir si
c'est possible des précisions sur la
nature des boucles euh parce que j'ai vu
mention de ces boucles dans les articles
de presse s'agit-il de boucles d'élèv
qui fréquent les mêmes lycées ou les
mêmes universités s'agit-il de boucles
de jeunes qui habitent la même commune
ou le même quartier ou s'agit-il de
boucles à caractère communautaire
j'aimerais bien avoir des précisions sur
la nature des boucles parce que autant
les réseaux sociaux c'est publ on sait
très bien comment ça fonctionne mais la
nature et le les caractéristiques des
boucles m'interpellent et m'intéresse
beaucoup plus que tout le
reste merci Monsieur Bourg Madame
Laurence
aribet merci monsieur le Président et je
voudrais vous remercier pour la
l'intérêt que de de ce que vous nous
avez dit j'auraai deux questions une
question en prolongation de ce qui vient
d'être posé sur la sur les variations
territoriales parce que vous les avez
évoqué mais ça serait intéressant de de
d'aller un peu plus loin est-ce que vous
avez des éléments là-dessus et le le la
deuxième question c'est est-ce que on
peut faire est-ce que vous l'étude que
vous avez faite et et vos travaux
permettent d'aller plus loin dans le
croisement entre les motivations et la
nature des peines euh qui ont été
euh infligés
euh et est-ce qu'on peut faire une
gradation entre banalisation de la
violence et de l'agression et puis euh
euh des choses qui euh qui sont
peut-être moins grave comme la notion
d'opportunisme que vous avez souligné
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a
possibilité dans vos parce que vous avez
pas pu tout détailler mais est-ce que
vous avez les outils qui permettraient
éventuellement à des chercheurs après
d'aller un peu plus loin dans le dans le
dans le
travail merci Madame alors pour les
réponses dans l'ordre que vous
souhaiterez rép euh je peux commencer un
peu sur les mortiers mais après tu
continuer pas le stage citoyenneté
peut-être patri alors pour reprendre
peut-être dans dans l'ordre
effectivement euh d'abord dire qu'il ne
nous était pas demandé de procéder à des
recommandations sur notamment tel ou tel
point que nous observerions euh
néanmoins s'agissant des mortiers
d'artifice ou
autres matériel pyrotechnique comme je
l'ai indiqué il a été noté que dès le
premier soir ces outils étai utilisés ce
qui laisse supposer qu'ils sont à ce
moment-là à disposition
euh nos auditions et l'examen des
dossiers que nous avons
euh
réalisé sur ce point euh laisse
apparaître à la fois des
euh réseau d'approvisionnement soit via
Internet et des achats même avec des
prix cassés vous l'avez indiqué des
promotions ou bien des euh déplacements
à l'étranger en Belgique ou en Pologne
pour euh
s'approvisionner ce qui euh peut-être
mon collègue pourra compléter a pu
laisser supposer des liens avec des
réseaux de délinquence plus structurés
que euh initialement euh évoqué
euh c'est c'estes mortiers et euh sont
donc diffusés dans ses réseaux sociaux
effectivement enfin enin où ils sont en
en vente les les motivations à ce
moment-là pour les les les utilisés ne
sont pas véritablement développés en
tout cas sur sur les réseaux je je
reviendrai sur les réseaux sociaux mais
peut-être pour les mortiers Pascal sur
ce que dit
les sur les mortiers donc on a on a une
réglementation qui qui on interdit le
commerce bien évidemment la difficulté
c'est que
euh on passe au-dessus de la
réglementation puisque on va les
commander à l'étranger sur Internet et
on les reçoit par colis postal euh donc
on est sur un schéma qui s'apparente à
un schéma de de de trafic de matières
dangereuses donc la la la difficulté
pour les pour les services enquêteurs
sera de
travailler sur la question des mortiers
à des périodes spécifiques de l'année
avant le 14 juillet avant le 31 décembre
ceux d'entre vous qui sont originaires
de l'Est de la France peuvent connaître
le problème euh donc ce sera un enjeu
voilà ce sera un enjeu la réglementation
est en ce qu'elle est il va falloir
travailler là-dessus les les les
services d'après ce qu'on nous dit
travaille
là-dessus mais c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que d'interdire simplement la
la
commercialisation après sur sur l'usage
des mortiers on est quand même sur une
escalade sur une escalade notamment dans
l'affrontement avec les forces de
sécurité intérieure et c'est quelque
chose qui était un peu
nouveau en terme de densité pas en terme
de d'effectivité ou ou de réalisation
mais sur cet épisode la la densité des
attaque de policiers ou gendarmes au
mortiers a été quand même très forte et
plus forte que que
jamais et par rapport effectivement donc
à ce ce qu'on pouvait qualifier de
incant peut-être plus chevronnés de
réseaux déjà constitués sur lesquels qui
avaient été à l'œuvre dans la fourniture
de ces engins
pyrotechniques qui même si des prix
étaient cassés sont relativement onéreux
on a eu aussi un certain nombre de
témoignages
d'approvisionnement sur enfin de de de
mise en main de ces engins pyrotechnique
notamment entre les mains de de mineurs
qui arrivaient sur les lieux et auquels
des majeurs distribuer euh ses engins
pyrotechniques
euh sachant que dans certain un certain
nombre de procédures d'ailleurs ils ont
été utilisés euh enfin
véritablement le mineur ne savait pas
s'en servir c'était c'était évident
voilà donc c'est vrai que ces
profils plus euh plus chevronnés euh
seront certainement à à à évaluer pour
ça rejoint un peu la question des des
réseaux sociaux alors là encore euh on
vous l'a dit nous avons consulter des
dossiers nous avons vu les dossiers nous
avons les auditions des personnes sont
des déclarations donc euh nous ne
faisons qu'avec le matériau qui nous a
été soumis qui peut être comme on l'a
dit aussi euh
euh parfois orienté par euh des motifs
de défense euh au moment où euh les
personnes sont sont sont présentées euh
sur ces boucles on a observé les deux
c'est-à-dire des boucles vraiment de
proximité
euh des copains euh qui euh sont du même
quartier du même endroit qui s'ennuient
qui savent pas quoi faire et qui vont
alors puisque j'ai dit que la moitié des
personnes avaient commis l'effit dans
leur commune la moitié se sont déplacées
mais par exemple si je vous livre des
ver bâtimes voilà l'und dit comme je
vivais dans une ville très calme il ne
se passait rien dans ma vie j'ai donc
voulu aller dans une ville où il se
passe c'est des trucs prendre des vidéos
et regarder donc en fait ils sont 8 ou
10 là dans cette c'est une toute petite
commune rurale alors on reviendra sur et
et ils s'ennuient et ils vont aller se
déplacer dans la ville où semble-t-il il
y a plus d'activités donc des réseaux
des petits groupes là c'est plutôt
WhatsApp du coup qui est utilisé et puis
ensuite des réseaux sociaux utilisés
parce que ils font la promotion le des
des violences des de ce qui se passe
parce que ils sont vécu également comme
facteur de valorisation par ces jeunes
qui voi le moyen de se retrouveré euh
extrêmement valorisé je si je prends
encore des des verbattimes voilà j'ai
euh j'étais matrixé j'étais dans une
matrix W ou dans un engrenage j'avais
des milliers de commentaires donc c'est
quelque chose qui euh euh valorise où
j'ai des vidéos de gens qui tirent des
feux d'artifice j'ai toujours voulu être
reporterur voilà donc euh on a les les
les deux ensuite euh pour répondre plus
finement à votre question euh je crois
qu'on n' pas pu avoir ce détail de
savoir si on était euh dans quelque
chose de plus vous avez je crois utilisé
le terme de communautaire euh euh ça
nous ça nous a pas été indiqué en tout
cas un engrenage de valorisation et de
lutte enfin de surencher entre groupes
entre villes entre communes voilà il
fallait montrer ce qu'on avait pu faire
ou ce qu'on savait faire voilà euh quand
on parle des réseaux sociaux on nous a
cité aussi
[Musique]
les chaînes d'information en continu
hein et puisque là aussi certains disent
bon je vous lis pas le c'est extrêmement
vulgaire donc je vous le lis pas mais
voilà on nous a dit autant passer à
faire quelque chose autant passer sur
avec le nom d'une chaîne en continu pour
dire voilà combien
céta nous sommes EXM nous m'arrêter au
au prononcer de la condamnation euh
puisque certaines venaient à peine
d'être prononcé don don dont nous avons
pris connaissance peine de stage de
citoyenneté nécessite du du du temps
enfin pas nécessairement très long mais
plusieurs semaines le temps qu'il soit
mise en œuvre donc pour nous ça a été ça
a été hors champ de notre de notre
périmètre mais dans notre rapport nous
avons néanmoins souligné d'une part on a
utilisé le terme de réancrage dans la
citoyenneté d'un certain nombre de
condamnées et pour nous effectivement la
peine de stage de citoyenneté nous
apparaissait être comme quelque chose
enfin un outil et une sanction
pédagogique à ce titre-là euh en
revanche nous avons aussi indiqué que
euh peut-être faudrait-il adapter le
contenu de certains stages donc ça ça
dépend je dirais des des ressorts des
des des tribunaux puisque le le contenu
est défini essentiellement localement et
peut-être effectivement trouver une
réponse ou un contenu qui soit
spécifiquement adapté au profil de de
ces ametiers alors ça existe déjà tant
la la la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse que l'administration
pénitentiaire par exemple propose des
stages euh ciblés sur les auteurs de
rodéo urbains donc on est sur une autre
dimension mais mais on est capable
d'adapter le le contenu des stages à
certains types d'infraction et
effectivement il nous est apparu
important de souligner qu'il y avait
peut-être un contenu spécifique à
réintroduire sur tout simplement ce qui
est vivre vivre dans la nation alors il
y avait une question qui était proche
aussi qui était sur la la l'adéquation
le croisement je crois entre
les les motivations et la nature des
peines donc c'est voilà c'est
c'est nous avons fait des croisements
alors nous n'avons pas fait ce
croisement
spécifiquement mais ce qui nous est
apparu alors deux points ce qui nous est
apparu le premier c'est que la peine
était surtout je dirais corrélée à la
nature et à la gravité de l'infraction
c'est c'est ce qui nous a vraiment euh
euh je dirais paru le le le le le plus
évident et le deuxième point je crois
que ma ma collègue vous l' indiquer
c'est que les
motivations faisait aussi partie de la
stratégie de défense c'est-à-dire que
très clairement nous avons pris avec
quand même beaucoup de précautions ce
qui était ce qui était avancé puisque ce
ceux qui se sont exprimés c'était
essentiellement dans les procès verbaux
dans d'enquête d'audition mais aussi
dans dans dans les déclarations à
l'audience et peut-être aussi dans les
déclarations qu'ils avaient faites
auprès des des services en charge des
enquêtes de personnalité bien évidemment
il mesurait les enjeux de ce qu'il
disait et donc je dirais que les
motivations nous paraissaient quand même
assez asceptisé ou atténué par rapport à
ce qui pouvait peut-être être les les
réelles motivations c'est pour ça que je
pense que ça probablement moins joué que
la nature la nature des
faites et peut-être je complète pour
répondre à madame la sénatrice sur la
variation
territoriale nous avons effectivement
détaillé dans le rapport le proportion
d'infraction selon les les communes et
indiquer que 7 % des infractions donc je
je l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire 20
3 % sont en zone gendarmerie ce qui pour
nous est beaucoup plus significatif
qu'en 2005 donc sur la la le le nombre
de communes concernées nous nous on est
évidemment nos facteurs zone gendarmerie
zone police 7 % donc des infractions ont
été commises dans des communes rurales
15 % dans des unités urbaines de moins
de 50000 habitants 8 % dans des unités
urbaines de entre 50000 et 100000
habitants et 70 % dans des unités
urbaines supérieures à 100000 habitants
voilà donc on
reste enfin évidemment avec une
proportion importante sur les unités
urbaines les plus importantes et je l'ai
dit l'Ouest France idien mais aussi des
communes rurales et des tout petites
communes et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes allés quand je vous ai dit qu'on
avait fait un panel sur 32 tribunaux
judiciaires hexagonaux nous nous sommes
intéressés aux tribunaux aussi dans des
villes qui n'avaient pas connu notamment
en 2005 de telles violences et
donc de plus petites de plus petits
tribunaux de plus petites communes qui
ont
été concernés nous sommes aller voir les
les dossiers les réponses pour pour nos
travaux voilà si j'ai
répondu merci Madame il y a une question
de Madame
Floren merci monsieur le Président euh
je viens de prendre connaissance d'une
étude en fait et d'une analyse comparée
de deux chercheurs de Sciences
Po qui est paru le 10 octobre dernier
qui concerne une analyse comparée
socio-territoriale des émeutes de
2023 et euh qui rejoint évidemment en
partie ce que ce que vous avez dit mais
je voulais vous interroger plutôt sur le
leur analyse qui fait apparaître
contrairement à 2005 deux temps euh un
premier temps qu'il qualifie
d'émotionnel qui est surtout dirigé
comme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs contre
les forces de l'ordre et les biens
publics et qui se situe essentiellement
en région parisienne et un second temps
lui pour pour le coup beaucoup plus
insurectiontionnel comme il le qualifie
qui là concerne un plus jeune de des
auteurs be beaucoup plus jeune que vous
avez vu et qui rentre plutôt dans la
catégorie je j'imagine des mineurs euh
et là beaucoup plus diffus sur le
territoire et s'attaquant euh sur
élargissant je dirais leur leur leurs
attaques sur les commerces et se
dirigeant vers sur l'ensemble du
territoire dans des plus petites
communes et et qui a créé ce climat
est-ce que votre analyse sur justement
les les peines prononcées confirment ces
ces deux temps et cette analyse de ses
auteurs collègue madame Elsa Schalk et
ensuite madame
lmeld merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur à mon tour de vous remercier
madame messieurs pour pour cette
présentation qui nous permet d'avoir une
grille de lecture un peu plus
approfondie même si je pense qu'on peut
regretter que dans la lettre de mission
il n'it pas été état des mineurs tant
nous savons à à quel point les mineurs
ont été fort nombreux et ont joué un
rôle extrêmement important ce qui
interroge aussi sur d'autres ressort
notamment sur la question de la la
responsabilité
parentale lorsque on voyait en fait ces
mouvements ces ces violences ces émeutes
nous avons vu que les symboles de la
République étaient attaqués avec des
écoles avec des mairies et donc avec une
signification forcément importante et
vous avez souvent évoqué la question du
défi déficite de l'ancrage citoyenne et
je voulais savoir justement à la lumière
de ces atteintes à la République si vous
faisiez justement ce ce rapprochement là
si c'est aussi notre République qui a
été attaquée et les valeurs que la
République justement représente je vous
remercie
M merci monsieur le Président à mon tour
également de vous remercier pour
l'ensemble des informations que vous
nous nous avez délivré ce matin qui
recoupe cela a été dit par certains de
mes collègues finalement assez largement
ce qu'on a pu constater sur le terrain
en tout cas qui recoupe ce que moi j'ai
pu constater à la fois dans ma ville de
Lille et plus largement dans le
département y compris dans la partie
plus rurale de ce département et aussi
sur la question des mortiers donc je
vous confirme qu'effectivement une bonne
partie d'entre eux viennent de Belgique
on a on a pu malheureusement le voir on
l'a vu avant les émeutes hein on n'a pas
découvert les mortiers avec ces émeutes
et comme vous l'avez dit on les
retrouvera sans doute aussi après ces
émeutes moi je j'aurais souhaité avoir
si c'est possible quelques précisions
même si j'ai compris que ça ne rentre
pas directement dans dans le cadre de la
mission sur les chiffres que vous avez
donné sur les mineurs vous nous avez
indiqué que 36 % d'entre eux étaient
franciliens on sait qu'en Île-de-France
il y a quelques département
particulièrement jeunes mais il y a des
départements jeunes aussi au nord de
l'île-de-fance et j'aurais voulu savoir
si vous aviez quelques précisions sur
les mineurs dans les autres départements
de notre pays merci merci madame
monsieur
Bitz merci monsieur le Président merci
pour les travaux qui ont été présentés
deux petites questions parce qu'on a
parlé du prononcer de la peine par
contre je à moins que j'ai été un petit
peu étourdi j'ai pas entendu parler du
nombre de mandats de dépôt qui ont pu
être délivrés euh à la à la suite du
prononcer et le nombre de peines qui
aurait été immédiate
aménagé c'est quand même un élément
effectivement enfin à mon sens important
quant à la au rappel fait par la par la
justice deuxième point concernant les
les mineurs j'ai bien compris que vous
étiez intéressé dans dans le champ de
votre mission à seulement ceux qui
avaient été co-auteurs d'infraction avec
les personnes majeures incriminées j'ai
bien noter qu'ils étaient tous
apparemment en dehors du champ de la
prévention spécialisée que personne les
connaissait qu' découvre à à l'occasion
de ces de de de de ces émeutes qu'il y a
des jeunes qui ne sont évidemment pas
pas suivis j'aurais aimé savoir quelles
ont été les les conséquences par rapport
à ces mineurs dont vous avez eu
connaissance des situations vers la PG
mais également vers les services du
département chargés il me semble d'un
certain nombre de fonctions concernant
les mineurs qui peuvent être pris
effectivement euh en situation de
coaction avec des majeurs et qui peuvent
être considéré aussi comme méritant un
suivi social par les Conseils
départementaux et les services
spécialisés dans le domaine je vous
remercie merci alors il y a pas d'autres
questions j'ine que c'est la dernière
série donc dans l'ordre que vous
souhaiterez allez-y je vous en prie je
vais peut-être répondre sur les l'étude
l'étude récente effectivement par
sciencep qui qui qui d'ailleurs je crois
que c'est c'est nourrit de notre rapport
puisque elle nous cite à plusieurs
reprises
euh alors nous l'avons dit qui aussi je
crois que ma ma collègue l'a rappelé euh
nous avons aussi observé ces ces C ces
deux phases si vous voulez euh ce qu'on
a appelé la la la la cinétique de de des
événements et effectivement très
clairement il y a une première phase
avec un nombre important d'infractions
d'atteintes euh à l'autorité publique
d'atteinte au aux forces de l'ordre de
dégradation de de de biens publics qui
ont été majoritairement constaté et
effectivement au cours des premières
nuits et on a assisté euh à un
basculement euh probablement à partir du
30 juin qui a été la le 30 juin 1er
juillet les les les journées où le plus
grand nombre d'infractions ont été
commises ou où où les les faits se sont
étendus sur le territoire national et où
les atteintes au bien c'est-à-dire en
clair les les vols aggravés et les
dégradations de
biens ont pris ont pris le dessus
et sont devenu extraordinairement
dominantes euh votre question c'était
euh
euh le
rapport entre les deux on n'a pas
nécessairement euh à travers le prisme
qui a été le l're c'estàd quand même
très limité ceux qui ont été identifiés
et condamné au 31 juillet nous en avons
vu de de qui avait participé au à tous
les types d'événement euh mais
euh je je dirais que pour nous les
données étaient vraiment trop trop
éparce pour qu'on puisse en tirer des
des des conclusions ce qu'on constate
néanmoins c'est que le profil est
rigoureusement le même c'est-à-dire que
ceux qui ont qui qui qui ont pu tirer au
mortier par exemple contre des forces de
l'ordre ceux qui ont été appréender dans
dans des magasins en train de de de
voler pour nous il n'y avait pas
véritablement de de différence que ce
soit dans dans je dirais dans
euh dans la situation sociale que ce
soit aussi dans la la situation pénale
ce qui pour nous est d'ailleurs une
voilà probablement une des enfin une des
difficultés ou une des énigmes de
euh des motifs du passage à l'acte et de
la nature de de tel ou tel
euh mode d'action qui a qui a été retenu
comme comme le rappelait ma collègue il
y a une étude recherche sociologique qui
est en cours qui va aller beaucoup plus
en détail justement sur le le profil des
motivations qui je pense va va être
aussi très intéressé par par l'étude que
Don dont vous avez fait état euh et qui
euh probablement nous nous fournira des
des clés d'explication beaucoup plus
forte mais pour nous je dirais qu'il n'y
avait pas véritablement de de de de
catégorisation vers l'une ou l'autre
infraction je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
votre
question euh je peux répondre peut-être
s'agissant des mineurs
euh alors donc comme on l'a indiqué ça
ne rentrait pas directement dans notre
lettre de mission nous n'avions que la
coaction les mineurs en coaction et
comme pour avoir enfin un profil et
déterminer un profil des auteurs nousous
sommes limités à des auteurs
définitivement condamnés comme nous
l'avons dit pour ne pas
voilà englober des personnes qui ne
seraient pas reconnues ensuite auteur
par la justice or vous le savez les
règles de décision concernant les
mineurs son s'inscrivent dans une
temporalité différente de ceux des
majeurs ce qu'on peut peut-être préciser
c'est que tout comme pour les majeurs
les parquets ont fait le choix de
déferrement tous les mineurs quasiment
enfin 90 % des mineurs qui ont été
impliqués dans des violences urbaines
ont été déférés déférés ça veut dire
présenter devant soit une juridiction de
jugement soit pour même la mise en en
place de peinees alternatives puisque
pour ces mineurs dont on voit qu'ils
sont pour 68 % d'entre sans antécédent
judiciaire non connu des réseaux de de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
notamment et des d'une façon générale
j'allais dire des services
sociaux il y a eu un certain nombre de
rappels à la loi euh donc de de de peine
alternative on va dire qui euh ont été
fait sur desferments c'est-à-dire que
les parquets ont quand même choisi
d'avoir une position voilà de de les
faire venir au tribunal quelque chose
d'assez
euh impressionnant et de de de les
sanctionner de de la sorte en revanche
donc les les décisions doivent ensuite
pour ces ces mineurs he donc la
temporalité c'est une première décision
on va dire sur la culpabilité dans les 3
mois il y a à peu près 3 mois de délai
pour les jugés et ensuite dans les 9
mois euh pour un jugement définitif à la
fois sur euh la sur la peine hein la
culpabilité maintenant il y a deux temps
la culpabilité et puis la peine donc on
s'inscrit dans quelque chose qui est aux
alentours de 9 12 mois hein pour avoir
des décisions définitives pour des
mineurs donc évidemment c'était
incompatible avec nos délais de de de de
rapport nous avons juste pu donner c'est
ce que je vous ai indiqué quelques
renseignements sur le profil à partir
des données statistiques des des mineurs
impliqués donc il faut faire attention
mais là on a quand même ces éléments des
garçons 81 % de nationalité Fran de
nationalité franilien 36 % de de
franilien mais sans pouvoir être plus
précis
sur de l'origine des départements ex
exactement et ensuite une enquête qui a
été également réalisée par la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse à partir des
données déclaratifes qui figurent dans
ce qu'on appelle les recueils de
renseignements socio-éducatifs qui sont
les éléments déclaratifs recueillis
auprès du mineur éventuellement de sa
famille par les services de la
Protection Judiciaire de la Jeunesse au
moment du déferrement donc c'est
déclaratif c'est le jeune qui parle et
qui dit voilà et c'est là que on peut
observer 63 73 % environ de mineurs qui
sont scolarisés euh 68 % qui sont issus
de famillees monoparental et 68 % 68,2
sans antécédents judiciaaires voilà mais
beaucoup de prudence sur ces éléments
qui ne sont que déclaratifs et qui ne
sont pas qui ne concerne pas des mineurs
définitivement concernés définitivement
condamnés voilà voilà donc comme on l'a
dit il faudra l'étudier ultérieurement
voilà nous nous nous appelons à la
prudence sur ces éléments je sais pas si
on a répondu presque tout il reste une
réponse je crois peut-être juste en
complément pour pour le suivi par les
Conseils
départementaux en fait il faut il faut
distinguer là nous sommes en matière
pénale et les les les conseils
départementaux prennent en charge plutôt
l'assistance éducative donc plutôt le le
le volet le volet civil
néanmoins donc nous n'avons pas
d'éléments hein sur les mineurs
présentés au pénal la part de ceux qui
bénéficiaient déjà d'un suivi ou qui ont
donné lieu en plus à une saisine du juge
des enfants en matière éducative pour la
bonne raison quand c'était hors champ de
de notre mission en revanche ma collègue
vous a rappelé que la quasi-totalité des
mineurs mise en cause ont été déférés et
ces mineurs déférés ont dans leur
immense majorité fait l'objet de mesures
provisoires dans l'attente justement de
de de leur jugement et c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi des des des mesures
éducatives une prise en charge éducative
alors les termes sont les mêmes mais on
est au pénal mais les services de la PGJ
ont bien été
saisis avec un suivi éducatif pénal de
la quasittalité des mineurs qui ont été
déférés et pardon je rajoute pour
répondre être complète et répondre sur
les éléments de de peine je pense que
mon collègue la avait indiqué sur
l'incarcération 53 % euh d'incarcération
immédiate dans les peines prononcé 20 %
d'aménagement de à l'audience de de ces
peines à l'audience et 20 % des peines
qui entraîne un suivi pénitentiaire donc
surci probatoire travail d'intérêt
général détention à domicile sous
surveillance électronique euh donc ce
sont des
euh auteurs qu'on anné qui pourront
aussi être suivis enfin dont on pourra
voir l'évolution et qui pourront
peut-être rentrer dans l'étude puisqu'on
verra leur leur évolution je rajoute
aussi pour sur sur ces motivations et
sur les atteintes aux valeurs de la
République madame la sénatrice évoqué
que comme je l'ai
indiqué les les faits beaucoup de faits
nous ont certainement échappé un certain
nombre de faits notamment les faits les
plus enfin certains fait grave
d'atteintte des incendies de tribunaux
le tribunal de proximité d'ière qui a
été incendié des mairies qui ont été des
écoles comme vous le disiez font l'objet
d'ouverture d'information judiciaire
donc ce sont des procédures qui sont en
cours auxquelles nous n'avions pas accès
et et donc nous ne nous ne savons pas et
certainement ces éléments enfin et la
motivation les audition des des auteurs
dans ces faits beaucoup plus
significatifs sur ce que vous indiqueiez
des valeurs de la République seront à
venir nous arrivons au terme de notre
audition il me reste à vous remercier
Madame et messieurs je note tout de même
un point sur lequel nous allons devoir
travailler tout de même et qui est
inquiétant on évoquait tout à l'heure
l'usage des mortiers la facilitéage très
bien mais en fait ce qui m'inquiète
c'est le rapport décomplexé à la à la
violence alors on l'avait intégré bien
évidemment on sait depuis longtemps mais
ça veut dire que les choses ont changé
c'est que aujourd'hui tout est permis et
le degré de gravité n'est même plus
apprécié et encore moins respecté donc à
partir de là le sujet où le mal est sans
doute extrêmement profond et la réponse
n'est pas aussi simple qu'on veut bien
le dire elle prendra sans doute du temps
fa un petit billet d'humeur de fin de
séance qui nécessite naturellement
d'être un peu travaillé en tous les cas
merci merci à vous et chers collègues et
bien merci également à vous nous
suspendons la séance jusqu'à la
prochaine fois merci à vous